good afternoon cs109 how are you guys
doing today
oh fantastic okay that's why I liked
here I hope you guys had a wonderful
wonderful weekend I was gone for a
little bit last week but I am healthy
I'm back I'm here for the rest of the
quarter though as you know that's going
to include a Thanksgiving break coming
up pretty soon uh
oh my gosh is this one of my favorite
lectures ever you chose a fantastic
lecture to come to it is one of the most
interesting lectures in terms of
intellectual foundations for great ideas
it is one of the most used for lectures
we will be building machine learning
upon what we learned today uh and
certainly you'll see things like this in
the final in your sections uh and it
also happens to be a bit independent of
what we've talked about before because
it's such an exciting day for cs109
we've done counting Theory we've done
core probability we've talked about
random variables we talked about lots of
random variables being random together
then we have this wonderful little aside
where we went to uncertainty Theory we
learned about great ideas in the world
of probability
like the central limit theorem and we're
ready for the final section of cs109
where we take what we've learned about
probability and we create something
truly useful out of it uh which has this
big overarching label of machine
learning and today is the first class of
that new section how exciting so today
is the date where we Bridge from
probability Theory into artificial
intelligence sound good
yeah let's go do it let's go learn some
things okay so machine learning uh it's
a story of today's class and because I
was in kind of like a Disney mood when I
made this we're going to use Lion King
as our narrative for today so we're
going to be telling you this wonderful
story of machine learning
on some level the questions
that are posed by Machine learning have
already showed up in cs109 remember when
we did WebMD Health when we talk about
probabilistic models
we ended up with these wonderful things
called Bayesian networks and we got to
the point where if you knew all of these
conditional probabilities you could use
General inference and you could ask sir
any probability question you cared about
from this model
but there is this one question which
never answered which is where do those
numbers come from and a few times in
class I alluded to oh we can learn them
from data
and that's really what the focus of
machine learning is suspense
what's machine learning
at this point in cs19 if you're given a
model with all the probabilities
necessary you can make predictions which
is fantastic that's a really important
thing to know how to do but what if
somebody doesn't just give you a model
with all the numbers uh required what
would you have to do
you might have to actually learn all the
numbers in your model and this simple
problem turns out to be so deep and
complicated it is the heart and soul of
artificial intelligence
I want to lightly point out there is
another problem which is
um can we also learn the structure of a
probabilistic model from data too and I
just want to lightly note that that's so
cool but I'm going to try and you know
limit what I teach you in cs109 if it
was up to me I would teach you
everything I possibly know but it's it's
nice to have a self-contained class so
we're just going to focus on machine
learning and not structure learning
and that simple problem where do numbers
and models come from is the heart and
soul of this thing called machine
learning now machine learning as you may
know
is related to a few other terms machine
learning is one way of doing artificial
intelligence artificial intelligence
making programs that do something
slightly interesting and then machine
learning it says I'm going to learn how
to do something slightly interesting by
learning parameters from data
I do want to lightly note that you might
have heard of a thing called Deep
learning and deep learning is a
particular type of machine learning for
a particular type of model but it all
funder falls under this big
umbrella of machine learning
and this is what the rest of cs109 is
going to look like we will teach you
deep learning but before you learn deep
learning you need to know two of the
most classic algorithms in machine
learning which are called naive Bayes
and logistic regression and in order to
get there we need to build you a
theoretical foundation and this
theoretical Foundation has a name it's
called parameter estimation and it's a
nice unassuming name that covers a lot
of beautiful Theory
I'm going to teach you three ways that
you could do machine learning this
foundational Theory
for how you get parameters from data and
then we'll build these two algorithms on
top of it
unbiased estimators a thing called
maximum likelihood and Bayesian
estimation
sound good
oh let's do it
I do want to have a quick aside hey
can't we just like jump into using
tensorflow and start doing deep learning
right now
on some level you could every single
person in this room if you wanted to
just go pull up the most modern library
and train a deep learning algorithm it
wouldn't be that hard
the hard part would be is if you try to
do something creative on top of it if
you wanted to debug it or if you wanted
to kind of invent the next step in
machine learning and for lots of reasons
we think that there are going to be many
new steps and in cs109 the idea I would
like to give you is the theory behind
what happens in something like
tensorflow and it's not because I just
like love Theory and I think that's the
only thing that's important but because
the technology is on top of the theory
are moving quite fast knowing the theory
will help you invent the new
technologies it'll also help you stay
relevant as the Technologies grow so
while it'd be really cool to download
tensorflow I think it's really critical
that we all learn the beautiful
mathematics that go into this great idea
that has changed the world
do I have you hooked okay let's go do
this oh um
there are just to give you a sense of
some of the open problems
machine learning what we're going to
learn about traditionally uses a lot of
data so if you say hey computer learn
about the concept of a chair computer is
like I've got to if you give me like a
million examples or like okay here's a
million examples of a chair and then the
computer learns what a chair is but
humans are so much smarter and we've
talked about this before if I told you
there's a new symbol you've never seen
it before do you need a million examples
to start recognizing other versions of
the symbol no you guys can learn after
just one single training example how
clever are you
and this tells you the story of machine
learning is not done there is room for
improvement there are open problems for
you all to solve
so let's learn some Theory oh my Segway
okay and I will note that the open
problems that exist in machine learning
they're especially true for the human
problems that you might care about it's
for the places where artificial
intelligence interacts with uh needs of
humans there's a lot of problems that
people haven't really thought of and
there's a lot of open opportunities for
some advancement
so you guys want to push on these Grand
Challenge let's understand the theory
you want to understand how this thing is
really working like when people say
artificial intelligence what they really
mean you want to demystify that let's
learn the theory
and so our movie begins
we're going to learn parameter to our
estimation
parameter estimation is a simple idea
we've seen lots of probability
distributions and often those
probability distributions whether they
have single random variables or multiple
ones will have these special numbers and
these special numbers tell you what the
distribution is
those special numbers have a name
they're called parameters we call these
parametric models because you know if
you wanted to define a whole normal you
don't have to describe every single
point in that bell curve you just have
to give me two numbers these two
parameters if you want to describe a
poisson you don't have to describe every
single point in the probability Mass
function of a poisson you just give me
the Lambda
so any model which is defined by numbers
we call parametric models and the
parameters are where the real model
comes from
so I can tell you that something's
poisson
but if you really want to solve problems
using that random variable you'd need to
know what Lambda was
and I can tell you I have a whole
probabilistic model but if you don't
have values for all of your parameters
then it won't be able to do very many
interesting things for you
a little bit of notation we're going to
now start referring to all of these
different things as parameters and we're
going to start using the symbol Theta to
represent parameters in general does
that sound good
often Theta will be just like a single
parameter but sometimes models like a
normal might have more than one number
and so you can think of theta as a
vector
just to be clear in this terminology of
parameters because we're going to be
learning parameter estimation in our
beautiful Bayesian networks there is a
lot of numbers and those numbers those
are all parameters too and the name of
the game for today's class is getting
all of these parameters from data cool
rocking any questions on terminology
and this fits the general machine
learning format the general of machine
learning format has three major stages
the first major stage is you have a real
world problem and you model it you say I
think this is a poisson or I have a
Bayesian Network that's going to
represent this problem and you end up
with a formal model but that formal
model has a bunch of numbers left to be
filled in these numbers that we call
parameters so that's stage one in
machine learning stage two of machine
learning is okay somebody just gave you
a model
they say that there's going to be
numbers but we don't know what those
numbers are
but they also give you training data and
from this training data we're going to
choose really wonderful values of thetas
so that we're end up with a model filled
with numbers and then we can answer
probability questions
so that second stage parameter
estimation has another name called
training which you might sometimes hear
because it's coming from it's getting
its estimate for the parameters from
training data
okay so here's our pass and I have wild
news for you guys
we need to be able to estimate these
parameters but we already have some
methods for estimating parameters and I
just want to revisit them really quickly
before we jump into more General methods
the first way we have for SMA parameters
is called unbiased estimators so you
know if I told you
we have a bunch of data
and they're all IID
because the central limit theorem we
know that this is always a sample mean
and and we derived earlier that the
sample variance also has a close form
equation
this applies for any data set so if you
have a data set
we already have a method for estimating
the mean and the variance which means if
like you had to fit a gaussian
and you just had data points you kind of
have a method for already estimating
parameters it's not very general it'd be
hard to imagine how you could use this
for like your Bayesian Network
but in some sense we do already have
some really basic tools for estimating
parameters from data
we call these are unbiased estimators
and that's just because in expectation
this will be the right number It won't
always be the right average but in
expectation it will be the true average
this number
your guess for variance won't always be
the right variance but in expectation it
will be the right value
and these just leave so much to be
desired they just don't solve parameter
estimation in general what we're going
to learn about today is maximum
likelihood estimation the theory behind
a general method for choosing numbers in
a model
okay
and to drive that home there's lots of
different algorithms or things I could
show you which are hard to fit and I do
want to pull up our course reader by the
way we've been writing a whole bunch of
new things in the course reader there's
a whole bunch of new examples but you
know one example of something that'd be
really hard to fit using unbiased
estimators would be this new model I
give you called a mixture of gaussians
it says there's some gaussian a and some
gaussian B and there's
um every data point is more likely to
come from B than a and all together this
leads to one probably distribution I
know that there's these five parameters
I can tell you how they're related but
you have to guess the numbers this is
very difficult using something like
unbiased estimators so we need a more
General tool
so enter this great idea in machine
learning and to do that I want to go
back to a gaussian I want to go back to
the problem of estimating parameters I
don't want to use unbiased estimators
but I want to show you a demo which
highlights a new way of thinking and
this new way of thinking will give us a
general way for doing parameter
estimation ready let's do it
I have a classic
version of parameter estimation problem
for you
I give you all of these data points
I give you a model I say that I think
these data points come from a gaussian
you now need to do parameter estimation
which means you have to give me a mean
and you have to give me a variance you
have to give me the numbers of the
parameters
we already have a way of doing that but
I want to solve this problem using a
different method
what I'd like to do
is I'd like to
focus on a simple idea
see up here
I have different values of these
parameters and in this graph I do
something interesting
these vertical lines are all the data
points that you're trying to come up
with parameters to describe is that
making sense
and here are guesses for mean and
variance
I calculate this expression called
likelihood
and likelihood just says
if this was the true mean and this was
the true variance
what's the probability of you seeing
each of these points so what's the
probability of seeing this point under
those parameters times this point times
this point times this point times this
point
and the crazy idea is I'm going to let
people play around with these numbers
and we're going to watch likelihood go
up or down
so if these are our data points this
blue line is parameter mean equals five
and standard deviation equals three do
you guys want to see me make standard
deviation bigger or smaller
okay watch what happens when I make it
smaller see that likelihood expression
it's currently 4 times 10 to the
negative 19th
whoa it changed a lot did it get bigger
or smaller
yeah it got bigger so it used to be four
times since the 19th now it's almost 7
times 10 to the 19th it almost doubled
in likelihood there's still a very small
number but that very small number got
bigger
so that's saying if you had those
parameters your data looks more likely
it's more probable that you would have
seen the data you saw under these
parameters
doesn't say that these are the best
parameters it's just more likely than
the other ones we tried but we can try
other ones do you guys want to make this
variance bigger or smaller
okay and we can keep going and I'm going
to keep going and I'm going to stop when
the likelihood starts to go down so it
got went up it went up
it went up
it went up oh this is very exciting
it went oh up it went up oh definitely
better with smaller variances
oh this is great
will it just keep going up no no no it's
no longer going up
but you know maybe I haven't changed
this parameter I can change this one oh
that got worse
oh that got better it got better when I
made the mean a little bit higher oh
fantastic no
okay I like those ones
did you see what I did here what a funny
way of choosing a mean and variance
so what did I do here I said I'm gonna
just twiddle around with these numbers
until the data starts to look more
likely
and to be clear the likelihood in this
situation
I'm going to use l for likelihood it's
just the product
over every single data point
the probability density function of that
data point in the world where
you have that particular mean equals 5.5
and the standard deviation equals 3.0
1.1
so it's just saying you know every
single data point look of its
probability density function and
multiply it together and then my crazy
idea was we're just going to twiddle
around the values of the parameters
until this goes up the most
crazy
do you guys buy that that would work
did you know that most AI has a human
being behind the screens and they're
just like twiddling numbers until
likelihood goes up there's a secret like
inside your smart watches actually a
tiny little person who's being like yeah
actually let's make a variance go up a
little bit no that's not how it works
okay so this is a really cool idea this
is a powerful idea which is that for any
model you have
one very reasonable theme for how you
could choose your parameters is choose
whichever parameters
makes the data look pretty likely
and we haven't talked about how a
computer could do this automatically
we've just given you a perspective on
how we could choose parameters
in that perspective I like to think of
this metaphor of there's this big sound
board and you're like a sound engineer
and when you're choosing parameters
you're just trying to choose the values
that make your data look as likely as
possible in the world of your model and
you can twiddle those sliders a little
bit and each slider is a parameter's
value until it's like the perfect sound
and by Perfect sound I mean it makes the
data look so likely
did you guys oh
okay the first insight then that we've
got so far and this is a critically cool
idea in the world of probability
is that we should find which parameters
maximize a measure of likelihood
and that's going to require us to think
about arguments that maximize something
else I want to think about which values
of mean and standard deviation maximize
this thing arguments that maximize have
you guys ever seen a thing called ARG
max if not what a beautiful day in your
lives we're going to be talking about
arcmax
first of all this is a general
conversation let's take a step back from
probability let me give you a function
this function is negative x squared plus
five and I've so helpfully drawn our
function oh what a cute little function
it looks like a rocket ship
first of all
have you guys ever seen a Max function a
Max function can take in
an expression
and it will tell you what's the largest
value that this expression can take
so think about it for a second I'm going
to have you shout it out
what is the maximum value that this
expression can take on and you can look
at my handy little chart
I think about it three two one all
together
that was like kind of like a a d flat
but can we do that like a c like five
okay one two three
no five
I was getting there let's see if we can
nail it with the ARG Max now Max is a
thing that we all feel comfortable it's
the largest value that this can take on
and we've decided that this is a five
the ARG Max is a different concept it
doesn't care about the largest value it
asks the question what input leads to
the largest value so if I took that
exact same expression instead asked what
is the argument that maximizes it I will
get a different answer and in C in three
two one
zero
zero okay one two three
oh okay it's getting better but we
should definitely be sticking to
probability
I kid I kid so the difference between
five and zero here is five is the
largest value you can take on and zero
is the input which maximizes it and this
is a very important concept because
we're not really interested in How
likely is our data what we're really
interested is which input of mean and
standard deviation made the data look as
likely and that will be an ARG Max
a beautiful piece of theory that you
must know about the ARG Max
is what happens if you take the ARG Max
of the log of a function so imagine you
cared about the ARG Max of a function
mind-blowing claim for you
ARG Max of a function is the exact same
as ARG Max of a log of a function you're
like what no it can't be the same
they're close right no they're not just
close they're the same
so if you take your function from before
so if I said what is the ARG Max of
negative x squared plus five it is
giving up my whole C thing and how about
what's the ARG Max of this
zero that is my claim for you is that if
you take any function the argument which
maximizes the same as the argument which
maximizes the log of that function and
it's a crazy thing but it comes from
because of a very simple property log is
monotonic
if you put larger numbers into a log
you'll get a larger number back and
because of that
whichever number led to a larger value
of your function or log of a function we
know that it must have been the same
large output for the function itself so
because log is monatomic there is this
one critically important claim
whichever mean and standard deviation
maximizes this expression
will be the exact same mean and standard
deviation which maximizes the log
of this expression
and that expression is the pi of f of x
i
that is just a copy of that
insanity
so let me pause here for a second and
see like you know what's interesting
about this to people
yes do you still in the case where we're
dealing with smaller probabilities we
can just take the log of them and get
the argument yeah you're seeing exactly
where I'm going can I go back to that
demo I gave you
did you notice how I had likelihood and
it's this tiny tiny tiny number
notice how below it I also had a thing
called log likelihood
that's just the log of this likelihood
and when I was changing both of these
numbers were going up
like the likelihood would go up and the
log likelihood would go up with it
because the monotonic property of logs
and this is a beautiful thing for two
reasons one computers kind of are not so
good at representing very very very very
very very small numbers and computers
are much better representing logs of
those numbers and then there'll be
another reason but I want to be
mysterious a little bit
so hold on to my other reason but you
see exactly where I'm going
so where have we been in this lecture a
beautiful idea like we have this crazy
important goal everyone in cs109 needs
to how know how to choose numbers for
models
maximum likelihood starts with this
beautiful idea choose the parameters
that make your data look as likely as
possible
and then the next idea I've got for you
is okay now we've got to choose these
numbers well we'll need to do an ARG Max
and we can do the ARG Max of the log
likelihood instead
okay
so the ARG Max of some function is
always the same as the ARG Max of a log
and logs we love we like have a soft
tender part in our hearts for logs we
see logs and you're like you've done a
solid so many times and like we we like
let's chat a little tear for happiness
when we see logs because so many things
become much easier
a lot of equations will simplify like
log a b a times B is equal to log a plus
log B
um and actually it is worth noting when
I mention logs I don't often write a
bass because I actually mean the natural
base some people would write this as Ln
but I've gotten the habit of just
calling this log
okay
we've developed a few critical pieces
we're ready to start putting things
together
maximum likelihood estimation I wrote it
out on one slide it's so important I
wrote the spark notes on the board so
you can always follow along
the great idea is you have a general
method for choosing numbers for a model
it starts by defining the likelihood for
one data point
the second goal is to come up with a log
likelihood function and then the simple
idea is we're going to state that the
optal parameters are which ones
are the ARG Max of the log likelihood
function and then finally once you've
stated that
you would then use an optimization
algorithm and the optimization algorithm
can help you find the ARG Max there's
lots of cool computer science functions
that can do ARG Maxes I will tell you
about a few of them in cs109
now
as I wrote up on the board what is this
likelihood function I've been talking
about well if you have IID random
variables that means they're all
independent so it says How likely is the
data given the current status of their
parameters and that will just be Loop
over all your independent data points
and talk about How likely each one is
given the parameters
we want to find the parameters that
maximize this that's the simple idea
when you start you will write down this
expression and you will replace this
with either the PDF if you have a
continuous random variable the probably
Mass function if you have a discrete one
or the joint distribution if it's some
sort of probabilistic model
okay
that's how you do step one and step two
is just take the log of this
so story so far you can choose
parameters by finding the ARG Max of the
log likelihood of our data
and to write this out an equation the
likelihood is the product
of the likelihood of each data point for
IID random variables the log likelihood
whichever parameters make this the
biggest will also be the parameters that
make this the biggest but this can be
much easier to work with and notice the
first thing that happens when you take a
log of this expression that log used to
live outside of the columns but remember
the log is like a tractor and the C is
the columns and it's like
and then you get the columns get
collapsed into the summation the logs
like I'm inside
that's just a general property of logs
if you didn't know
um
so log of all your data points will lead
to the sum of the log of likelihood of
each data point on its own
and then we're going to state that the
best parameters that we can guess and we
put funny little hats on things that we
guess is going to be the ARG Max
whichever parameter makes this as large
as possible
I want to take a moment for conversation
I want you to have a nice little chat
with the person next to you take two
minutes what is confusing about this
what's interesting about this what
questions do you have see if you can
come up with a good question with the
person next to you and then let's talk
about this all together what a crazy set
of ideas go for it
services
yeah okay
I can guess one of your questions like
what's this going to look like when we
apply it to a real problem we'll get
there in a second other questions that
have come up
curiosity is yes this isn't the
artifacts of the log wouldn't that be
Infinity like
what exactly are we doing there so
for any particular values of parameters
you can calculate log likelihood of your
data
and notice that as I change these
parameters that changes
and
it's not the case that Infinity so it's
saying that Infinity is the ARG Max is
saying if you put Infinity into these
numbers
then that would be your ARG Max of
course this is infinity but it's getting
there right
but if I put Infinity in front of
parameters look at my current value of
log likelihood it's negative negative
4549. that feels like it's better than
negative 300 but it's worse
so putting in infinite values into
parameters doesn't actually maximize the
log of the likelihood the thing that
maximizes the log of likelihood will be
the same thing that maximizes the
likelihood itself which will in fact be
pretty good guesses of our parameters
does that answer the question very very
good question
other questions come up yes
um on this Library you had like the
different steps for the maximum likely
algorithm
um yeah the first step was like deciding
a model for the distribution of your
samples
how do you like how do you do that how
do you decide what your model is good
question so this is assuming somebody
gave you a model so at this point we're
saying we're telling you your data is
gaussian we're telling your data is
predo we're telling you that your data
are joint samples from this tiny little
Bayesian Network and there's these
missing numbers in all of those models
and your job is to find the missing
numbers there is a different task of you
decide what the structure is yourself
and I'm going to leave that till 228.
good question though we can talk about
we've done that in bats we've like
touched upon structure learning a little
bit but this is the question of figuring
out parameters
you guys need to see this you need to
see this live because so far it's all
Theory and no application and you can
solve so many problems once you know how
to oh but we have a bad guy all right
Max we haven't talked about how to do
ARG Max
this would work great and we could apply
this if we knew how to do ARG Max but we
haven't talked about this at all I just
said do ARG Max and you're like okay
great I'll do ARG Max
two options I'm going to tell you the
first one you learned about in Calculus
class and we're going to start with that
it's just straight optimization
let's say I gave you a function negative
x squared but this time plus four just
to mix things up a little bit
and I said find the ARG Max of this
expression
you might just be able to look at the
expression and be like it's zero but
this is not supposed to be using your
visual cortex we're trying to solve this
using math how could we solve this using
math and you're like oh
my calculus teacher told me something
about this he she said that I should
find the derivative
and set it equal to zero have you guys
had a calculus teacher tell you
something like that thank you Mr Blanton
so if you look at this part that
maximizes
the arguments notice that there's a
derivative of zero out there
must be true at a Max that the
derivative must be zero so one of the
things that people will classically do
is they'll take the derivative oh
derivative is scary but we have wool
from alpha not so scary you put it in
Wolfram mass that tells you the
derivative of this is 2X
and you're like 2x what does that mean
well
if x is 3 that means that the derivative
at that point is six and so we can
figure out the derivative oh wait
where's my negative sign here
should be a negative sign cheeky Chris
turns out zero doesn't really mess
things up
negative 2x if x is 6 or 3 then your
derivative at that point is negative six
the slope is negative six at that point
we don't care about all points we just
can't swear this derivative is equal to
zero
so what we could do is we could say okay
take this derivative and tell me the
value of x which makes this equal to
zero and if you solve for the value of x
that makes this equal to zero you get
that okay
when x is 0 the derivative is zero so
this is a good hypothesis for a maximum
point
and that is one way of doing ARG Max it
has some downsides you could find the
worst possible parameters because this
could be a minimum uh and obviously it
might not scale when you get to bigger
and bigger models but this is just fine
for getting us warmed up we have our
first algorithm for doing ARG Max Yeah
question
function with multiple
um Maxes and mins no if there's multiple
Maxes and bins you have to do a Next
Level analysis you have to decide are
these Maxes and are these bins and you'd
have to look at the second derivative at
minimum so this works for pretty simple
things this will just get us over the
hump so I can show you some examples but
we're going to need keep in mind I want
a more satisfying ARG Max everyone
should want more satisfying art Maximus
okay
okay and this is all the notes of like
this is why this is so limited and don't
worry about it we'll just get a better
version later
so this is your general mle formula if
you wanted to find
um
parameter you say what's the likelihood
what's the log likelihood and then you
find the Der the value which maximizes
loglihood you do the ARG Max
let us start with kind of a medium
difficulty example
is not the hardest thing in the world
but it's going to be a pretty good way
for us to get used to doing this it
won't be like once you get use that mle
you can solve so many interesting
problems but let's start with something
that's in the Wheelhouse of what we know
an mle problem would generally look like
this I'm telling you my model in this
case my model is that every data point
has a single value and that value is
drawn from a poisson and I've seen you
know 12 different independent samples
from this thing that I'm going to call
data
if this is my data set
the challenge of mle is to estimate the
parameters and the parameters for
poisson is Lambda remember Lambda is
just the word for this symbol
x i when I use this notation I mean like
the ith value in my data points so if I
gave you these data points
how could we estimate Lambda
again for poisson we have some pretty
reasonable ways of guessing what Lambda
is from this you know maybe
could imagine a way of doing it without
going to a first principle approach like
mle but let's use this as our first
opportunity to go end to end with mle
you guys ready for it
you guys I'm just warning you you're
going to look like really really legit
mathematicians once you get used to mle
because the math looks super impressive
but really we're just always following
this formula but when you get back to
Thanksgiving I want to do a little mle
and just like let your parents see and
they're like wow kids learning so much
at Stanford okay
let's try this out
so
I'm going to use this notation for our
data points I gave you 12 data points
but now we're going to call them X1 to
xn why just to use a little bit of
notation
I'm assuming that every single one of
them are IID from the same poisson and
my job is to try and estimate Lambda
based on these data points and I'm going
to use this recipe the mle recipe and
the end results of the mle recipe is
going to be an estimate for Lambda it
starts very humbly you have to say How
likely is a single data point if I tell
you what Lambda is so if I told you
Lambda was 5 How likely is a data point
hardest part of Emily sometimes actually
no I want people to sit with it the
tension
what is the likelihood of one data point
okay I'm going to tell you
it's very simply the probability Mass
function for
uh for a poisson so if you go back to
your course reader and you say like I
have a plus off I told you what Lambda
was we can talk about How likely it is
that you saw a particular value x sub I
you can say what's the likelihood of
seeing x sub I well it's e to the power
of negative whatever your Lambda was
Lambda the power of x sub I and then x
sub i s factorial that's just the
probability Mass function and that's
really your first step so the first step
um is to just write what likelihood is
but that's just likelihood of one data
point
if we talk about the likelihood of all
of our data given a particular Lambda
because our data is IID the likelihood
is really this expression and this
expression is just going to be the
product of the likelihood of each data
point on its own you can't always do
this it has to be independent for this
to be true but because it's independent
this is true and then we can just plug
in this expression we had from one data
point and we're just going to multiply
it for different data points if you had
to calculate likelihood you'd write a
for Loop
and for everything you look at the value
you know from our previous slide you
take six and plug it in for x sub one
one for x sub 2 and so on and each time
you'd be able to calculate this inner
term product them all together and
that's the likelihood if I told you
Lambda would say five yes
what would it look like if this data was
wasn't independent like what else could
be run run don't even look back just go
okay uh if the data was not independent
you enter a really weird theoretical
world but good news almost all data is
assumed to be IID we almost always
assume that each data point is some
independent draw condition on the
parameters
like
uh I'm gonna give you an example but
then I'm going to tell you the first
thing a mathematician would do is assume
it's independent anyways
so um let's say these lambdas are like
how many people get processed by a
cashier
maybe like how long it takes one person
like one cashier to process a chunk in
an hour influences the next one because
it leaves a queue so there could be a
way that they're not actually
independent but guess what first thing
we're going to do is assume Independence
because none of the math ever works out
if it's not independent so IID often
assumption that we need
but most data actually it's a very very
very good assumption
okay at this point
if you gave me any value of Lambda I
could plug it in with my particular data
set and I could say How likely does my
data look in the presence of your Lambda
and we could play the game we play with
the gaussians where you're just going to
like twiddle on lambdas and you could
try all the different values of lambdas
but that's not so fun we'd like a
computer to do the twiddling for us
which leads us to The Next Step
we're going to try and find the Lambda
which maximizes this expression which is
the same as the Lambda which maximizes
the log of this expression and you're
like I have to do logs no we get to do
logs We Are The Humble users of this
beautiful tool which is the log
so I just write the log of the
expression I had before and remember the
first thing the log does is like I want
to go live inside the house and I'm
going to break down the columns as I go
there
okay great the log one inside the house
and you have like the log of this nasty
expression and you don't want to do it
but then you're like wait a second log
of e is a good time isn't it you're like
yeah that's just going to be negative
Lambda and you're like I can do log of
this expression plus log of this
expression minus log of this expression
and when I do log of this expression
that exponent just becomes something
that goes in front and look how nice
that is when I took the log
it turned this nasty expression into
something actually quite a lot easier to
work with the log is your friend the
other reason I was going to tell you why
we use logs is it makes math much much
easier so at this point we have a
special expression we call the log
likelihood
and the final thing we want to do is we
want to choose the Lambda which makes
this expression as large as possible
maybe when you put 5 in it's large as
possible when you put three and it's as
large as possible we would like to
choose the ARG Max of this log
likelihood
notice how I put
a derivative here
is because no matter which optimization
technique you use you will most likely
need to derive take the derivative of
this with respect to your parameters you
guys are ready for some calculus
definitely could use will for mouth from
here but we can do this one on our own
in fact this is the level of calculus
that I think would be nice to know how
to do on our own derive that expression
with respect to Lambda
okay you guys can think about it first
of all the derivative of a sum is just
going to be a sum of derivative so the
derivative will just move right into
this inner part and you're like
derivative of that term seems not so bad
during this term well it's got a log but
we can do that seems not so bad
derivative of this term looks awful
what's the deliverable factorial
oh my God we're gonna need like a smooth
continuous approximation but wait
somebody's shaking their heads why why
there's no Lambda
and if there's no Lambda the derivative
is just zero right as
Lambda changes how does this change Zero
fantastic what a beautiful thing
okay
now we're feeling brave we go into our
derivative so the derivative of that
term with respect to Lambda is well the
derivative is going to go inside the sum
the derivative of Lambda with respect to
Lambda just one so that was a negative
Lambda this becomes a negative one the
derivative of that log so X I log of
Lambda well the derivative of log of
Lambda is just one over Lambda and that
x i looks like a constant and as we
mentioned that negative log x i
factorial just goes away
so we have that this is the derivative
I'm then going to do this thing where
I'm going to take this derivative
and I'm going to move the sum as far in
as possible so that we really only deal
with the terms that have eyes in them
there's no I's here and there's no eyes
there when I move this sum through this
negative one it's like you add it up
negative one n times that just becomes a
negative n and when I move the sum into
this inner term it's like every single
term is multiplied by 1 over Lambda and
then you're summing up the X size so
this is how that term gets rearranged
at this point we have the derivative of
log likelihood with respect to Lambda
your Calculus teacher Mr Blanche doesn't
Mr Bland teach anyone else here
I don't know my Malaysian probability I
heard he went to Brazil and he taught
some people maybe you no
different probability or calculus
features but all of our calculus
teachers would have told us something
like if you want to find the value which
Max or maximizes you can take your
derivative set it to zero
so I'm going to take my derivative set
it to zero
and when I solve this expression for
Lambda I end up with Lambda equals the
sum over all my X I's
divided by n where n is the size of my
data set
wait a second that's like a screen
filled with mathematics
and at the end it just says take the
average of your data points
right this is saying like take all your
20 values add them up together and then
divide by how many values you have
you're like a page of mathematics for
what the sample mean
and yeah for poisson the maximum
likelihood estimation for Lambda says
you just average your data points and
that actually feels pretty good
and mle is Plus off for the sound this
is a this is a good time it's a good
news result it was a lot of math but it
led something that feels about right
okay I'm gonna make us do one more
simple example
before we jump into solving mle for
things we haven't seen the answer to yet
can we do one more simple example
let's drive this home Bernoulli oh man
consider random variables and we're
going to assume that they all come from
Bernoulli and you want to figure out
what is your best estimate for the
parameters what's the parameters or
Bernoulli ah yes p
and recall that your data
in this case is going to be like zero
one zero zero one one you know zero and
we're assuming that these are all iids
pulls from the same Bernoulli
with the same parameter p and we're
trying to figure out what is the best
value of P here
again
you could probably come up with a pretty
reasonable formula for how you could
have gotten this but I want to use this
opportunity to flex our mle muscles so
we're going to try and use all these
steps and derive it using mle
okay
First Step you have to drive the formula
for log likelihood it's going to be the
sum of the log of the likelihood of each
value
and at this point you're like okay
what's the likelihood of each value
it's a Bernoulli
what's the probability Mass function of
a Bernoulli
and then you look up on the course
reader and you get something like this
and you're like I need to substitute
this into that equation if the Bernoulli
says
if your value is one the probability was
P if your value is zero your probability
was 1 minus P whatever P was
and that's really cute and very helpful
except it's not at all differentiable
wait I promise Bernoulli would be easy
oh no
I'm going to show you the slickest trick
and you need to learn this now because
you're going to see this in two two one
you're going to see in 229 and you're
going to see it in 220 X whatever
and they're not going to explain it to
you they're just going to say it as if
it was the most obvious thing in the
world
people don't use this as the probability
Mass function for a Bernoulli instead a
lot of times you'll see people write a
continuous version of that same table
so to be clear this table is saying the
probability of one is p and the
probability of zero is one minus P makes
sense
that's fine but this graph is not
differentiable and so people use a
different expression for the probability
Mass function Bernoulli you're ready for
it they use that
you're like what is that it is
particularly P raised to the power of x
times 1 minus P raised to the power of 1
minus X you're like what are you guys on
well it turns out this is a continuous
version of that expression let's try
plugging in zeros for x
if you plug in a 0 for X what's P to the
power of 0
this whole term goes away
and one minus 0 is what
one so like this whole term goes away if
you put in a zero for X you're left with
1 minus p
what if you put in a 1 for X well then
this whole term will go away because 1
minus 1 is 0. and that whole term goes
away and you're just going to be left
with a p
if you plug in a zero and a one this
crazy formula
picks up what this graph left off if you
were to graph it has values for like
what's the probability that your
Bernoulli gave you like a 0.3 and you're
like what that doesn't make sense it
just happens to make sense at the value
0 and 1 and it happens to be derivable
and just be clear if you put P equals
0.2 this would be a 0.2 to the power of
x times 0.8 to the power of 1 minus X
and that X and the 1 minus X are just
choosing whether or not you should use
this term or you should choose that term
insanity
but learn it live it love it now because
people are going to just State this as
if it were obvious in the future and
they will not explain it with a nice
little chart like this
okay so before I jump back into
Bernoulli's just know that this is a
continuous derivable version of the
probably Mass function of a Bernoulli
craziness okay so if you want to do a
Bernoulli using our good old friend
Emily you write the likelihood
and here instead of writing the bar
chart we're going to write that
continuous version of the probability
Mass function
then you say what's the likelihood of
all the data it's just the products over
all our IID samples so we're going to
Loop over all these values and then
either choose P or 1 minus P depending
on whether or not the value is one or
zero
then we do the log
and we do the log of this expression
yikes yikes oh wait actually quite nice
because the log of a product becomes a
sum of logs
you take the log of expression at this
point you have log likelihood and my
claim is you should choose whichever P
makes that equation as large as possible
Arc exit
how do you ARG Max it
derive it and set it equal to zero I'm
going to let you do this on your own if
you want but if you derive it in set it
equal to zero you'll end up with this
wonderful result that your best value
for p is equal to dremel
sum all your values divide by n
a whole page of mathematics and what did
we derive
just choose your P to be the sample mean
and it's the unbiased estimator is a
really fancy way of saying the sample
mean
so all this math and it says you should
use P to be sample mean it says add up
all these values and divide by n and
that's a good estimate for p that's what
mle says it says that will be the value
which makes this data look as likely as
possible but on some level that feels
pretty good for Bernoulli again it's the
unbiased estimator I promise it won't
always be the sample mean but first now
we can just be like that's a good time
we've done our math for two examples
poisson Bernoulli and both times they
led to a result that seems pretty
reasonable
and this is where we depart off into the
wild unknown
because we're going to be able to do
this for more and more interesting
problems
if n was 10 for Bernoulli I just want to
make this a little bit statualized so
imagine you have 10 data points and you
want to choose a value P just to make
sure we're all following along with what
we're trying to do here
you're assuming that all the data points
are Bernoulli you're assuming they all
share the same value p and we don't know
what p is
what is pmle
if this these were your data points and
I give you a few options you can say
that mle says that P should be one you
can say mle is that P should be 0.5
Emily says the P should be 0.8 and M
Alicia's P should be 0.2
talk about with the person next to you
see if you can answer this but also as
always try and come up with a really
good question because a better other
people in the class would benefit from
that too so think about this a quick
check what does mle of a Bernoulli tell
us
um
wow
.com
okay
in the note of C no I'm just joking okay
yay or nay
yes
people really felt sad for either like
we wanted it to be you but it's not you
almost ever in this class
um yeah and what we're saying is a good
estimate for your parameter is you know
sum up all your values in this case
there's 10 values if you add them up
you'll get eight and then divide by n
which is how many data points you have
and that's the mle estimate
for what it's worth a beta distribution
would give you a much richer
representation of your belief in the
probability so mles maybe we can
recognize one of the limitations here
it doesn't give us a rich representation
of of expressing how certain we are
instead it's just giving a single number
it's just coming with single number
estimate and that's what mle does Based
on data at a model it will give you just
a single number back
okay yay you guys got it right yay
um and you know we could have gotten it
by
our mle estimate I want to take a moment
though and talk about likelihood on its
own
so likelihood was a step that we used to
come up with our prediction for Theta
but it's an interesting step on its own
because it says How likely is the data
in the case of our particular power
setting to our parameters
and the likelihood if you were to write
it down
it says take p
and we saw eight examples of one so that
will be raised to itself eight times and
we saw two examples of zero so you'll
see one minus P two times and that's
what the likelihood is and we're going
to choose the PS that make this as large
as possible and the claim is that this
is the value of P which makes this as
large as possible just a little bit of
intuition but not that important
what is really important is this formula
you guys are going to use it in section
you're going to use it on your problem
set you're going to use it on the final
exam you will need to know this mle
formula for starting out with some data
and ending up with an estimate for
parameters
yeah okay there it is this is like our
little mle and we're like so proud
you're like welcome to the world Emily
I do want to mention that it's
incredibly General
the point of this
demo I'm about to show you where we
start with data and we're going to
estimate the parameters for mean and
variance using mle
the point of this is actually to give
you two pieces of insight and the most
important one being that mle works even
if you have more than one number you
have to estimate so for the gaussian you
have to estimate both mean and variance
so just to be clear my first little
example this was the game we were
playing we're trying to use choose the
mean and the variance which made our
data
look as likely as possible and now we
want to do that a little bit more
precisely we'd like to not have to use
guess and check
starts out with saying How likely is a
single data point if you tell me the
parameters and that is just going to be
the probability density function
this step is almost always just plug in
the PDF the pmf or the joint
distribution
then we're going to try to figure out
what are our parameters to do that we
first write log likelihood and then
we're going to try and figure out what
is the values of mean and variance which
maximize this
when we write down log likelihood
it's just going to be the sum of the log
of each of the likelihoods who feels
like doing this log oh
but and then you look at it you're like
okay that'll pull this term apart and
the log of e to the something is
actually quite nice and when you do this
it turns out to be you know negative log
of that constant and that whole e
disappears and you're just left with
what e was raised to the power of when
you do the log like logs and E's like to
cancel out so in fact the log of this
expression
led to something quite nice to work with
so at this point we have the log
likelihood for a normal and the real
learning experience for this one is
um oh by the way and then I just
distribute the sum so this expression
just a little bit of algebra gives you
this one when you move the sums have
this sum on the side and the sum on the
side
the real takeaway I want you guys to get
from this next example
is when you have log likelihood if you
have more than one parameter you can
choose them simultaneously
if you're using our original idea of
optimization you derive them with
respect to each parameter so you take
this expression derive it with respect
to mu and then you take this log
likelihood expression and derive it with
respect to Sigma which is your other
parameter if you derive it with respect
to Mu you'll get this equation which you
can set to be equal to zero if you drive
it with respect to Sigma don't worry too
much about the derivations Wolfram Alpha
could help you there but if you did it
you would end up with this derivation
which you could then set to equal equal
to zero
so here I have my log likelihood check
then I differentiate log likelihood with
respect to each parameter set to equal
zero
and
one final thing we could do is we could
solve for both mu and sigma in these two
equations you have two unknowns two
equations you're like hey Chris don't
have more unknowns these are not
unknowns these are your data points
so n is known X i's are known those are
all knowns the only two unknowns we have
are mu and sigma and if you solve them
simultaneously
you would get this result
you would get that uh
mean should be equal to wait a second
that answer we always get which is the
sum over all your data points divided by
n and if you were to solve for this
other equation plugging in your answer
for mean
you would end up with your estimate for
mle's variance is going to be equal to
take each of your data points subtract
off your mean estimate Square it and
then divide that by n
my big Point here is
not how you do this optimization with
setting it equal to zero my big point is
if you have multiple parameters it's not
a problem you will have to drive log
likelihood with respect to each
parameter
but then any optimization algorithm can
take it from there and the setting equal
to zero trick works in this case but
another trick I'll teach you in a bit
works as well
I did also want to highlight one funny
thing here
who thinks that this is a pretty
reasonable statement if you're guessing
the mean baselt data
add all your data points together and
divide by n does that seem like a pretty
reasonable way to choose the mean yes
the other claim that mle gives you is
that if you want to choose the variance
you use this equation
and does anyone take any issue with this
equation
like I take issue with this equation
yeah
remember there being an equation a lot
closer a couple classical or you have to
divide by n minor absolutely divide by n
minus one you're right and the claim was
if you try and estimate the variance
from data and use this equation you'll
get a number which is too small
because your guess for the mean was
going to be wrong you always guess
statistics wrong and this one is going
to be closer to each of your values as
such you're going to think that you're
varying around the mean less and it
turns out this magical minus one solves
it and makes it so that you are not
going to be on average underestimating
we call this a bias estimator so this is
a great guess for mean Based on data and
that's not a really great guess for
variance Based on data you're like mle
you let us astray yeah sometimes it will
do that so anytime we have like a
variance or standard deviation if we're
not dividing by n minus 1 to 10 35 by
definition yeah it will always be too
small
for any other estimators every estimator
will have an unbiased equation and so we
for mean this is the unbiased equation
and for variance it's got a minus one
and other estimators would need to have
an unbiased equation too
uh oh how about that one
how do you think that's not this is the
biased equation
okay
yes yes
when you say it's biased does it got to
do with the sample size or something I
was thinking maybe I'm using minus one
music when this happens so the minus one
does a magical thing it just kind of
counteracts the fact that this is going
to be a bad guess of me and it's going
to be too close to your data points and
the minus one really balances that up
but you said something very important
you said sample size which is a point
I'd like to get deeper into
if you have three data points this is
pretty wrong if you have 10 000 data
points for getting the minus one really
doesn't matter that much and what I'm
going to claim in a little bit is that
while mle doesn't always give you the
perfect estimate from your parameters as
your number data points gets larger and
larger it will get closer and closer it
will converge the right number
I want to drive this point home with a
hilarious example
let's say you want to do mle and you
want to choose a uniform what parameters
does a uniform have
Alpha and beta Alpha and beta what do
those represent
ative yeah the smallest value that
uniform can take on and the largest
value
if you wanted to do mle you'd start with
data and we'd tell you what values you
have for Alpha Beta it turns out I
actually constructed these ones with
Alpha equals zero and b equals one you
can know but normally you don't know
what these are and you're trying to
guess
if you change Alpha and you look at the
law likelihood value notice how it goes
up up up up up up up up up up and then
it plummets to zero
why is that well if you say the minimum
value that your data points can take on
is 0.2 and then you observe a 0.15 this
looks impossible
so the likelihood will just get bigger
but if you get as the minimum value gets
larger than your smallest value here
likelihood of your data goes to zero
same thing happens with the maximum the
maximum will have a pretty high
likelihood and always a positive
likelihood but if your maximum smaller
than the large value you saw
then it says your data is impossible
given this parameter an impossible and
probabilities expressed with the
probability of zero or a likelihood of
zero
so if you were to choose mle values what
value do you think you would choose for
Alpha you'd say that my Alpha here
is equal to 0.15
that is the alpha which made likelihood
the highest what would you choose for
the max value here for beta
what is the ARG Max of beta in this case
of that beta likelihood with respect to
Beta
0.75
I told you that the true Alpha and beta
that I used to generate this data was 0
and 1.
but when it had to choose its Alpha and
beta it chose different values
in fact I chose Alpha to be the smallest
value in this list and it shows beta to
be the largest value in this list
I want to show you this example to drive
home a point
um
it's this idea of when your numbers are
small it does this thing that we
intuitively would call overfitting it's
not trying to generalize to any data it
hasn't seen it's only trying to describe
the data it has so if it's trying to
describe these data points these are
pretty reasonable choices for Alpha and
beta but if you're trying to describe
data points you haven't seen as well
then these aren't really good choices
you want to use something a little bit
smaller than what the smallest value you
haven't seen
but anyways some qualities of mle
in the limit as data points goes
Infinity it's the best thing it's
potentially biased that we've seen
through the uniform and we've seen
through the gaussian it might choose bad
estimators for small data sizes but also
it's one of the most popular things ever
used in practice for parameter
estimation
okay
I'm going to show you a few examples
then I'll give us a minute to think
about it and then we'll spend 10 minutes
doing one problem together
on your problem set you're going to have
to do this you're going to do maximum
likelihood estimation of the wind I'm
going to give you a probability density
function and I'm giving you data and I
say choose the parameter Theta based off
this data and you're going to do exactly
this write the likelihood write the log
likelihood and then figure out which
value maximizes the log likelihood
in section you're going to do a old exam
problem on the final exam at one point I
said here is the distribution for length
of menstrual cycles if you take a
particular person who has menstruation
and they give you some data could you
choose the parameters that would make
their data look as likely as possible
this was last time I gave a cs109 final
I put this mle question I said how long
a phone lasts is known to be coming from
this thing called the reliability
distribution
it's a probably distribution we've never
seen before but if I gave you data
points like n data points could you
choose the single parameter which is
Alpha
and then one of my favorites is this one
and this problem I have put it into our
lecture for today
if you go to today's lecture we have
this exact same problem which says
I give you all these data points and you
know what these data points are they're
sizes radius of sand on the beach
which is like I got really like artistic
I was like I want to make art which fits
the distribution of the sand size on the
beach which is really like not that
important but what is important is you
might want to fit a Pareto distribution
based off data So based off these dis
data points
could you choose the alpha for this
particular random variable which is
called the preto we didn't study as one
of our core random variables but using
mle you could figure this out
this is the sort of thing you could do
sort of thing that could be on your
final exam in fact this was once on a
final exam to give you an idea I'm going
to give you guys your pedagogical pause
take a minute and then I'd like to show
you what this answer looks like so take
a minute and talk about this with the
person next to you or just take a break
and think whoa mle what a time to be
alive
thank you
whoa
studies
success
if I told you all of these data points
were pulled from this probability
distribution
and I said choose an alpha
now
I wrote this up and what you could do so
you can check along at home
but the answer to this starts with
saying okay
I'm going to figure out what Alpha is
and the way to figure out what Alpha is
is going to be using mle
but before I jump into this any
questions come up during your
pedagogical pause
okay
how could you choose this Alpha
what's the first thing that you have to
do the first thing you would have to do
is you'd have to say well I'm told the
probability density function for one
point but the first thing I really need
is the likelihood function there it goes
so the likelihood function and I often
think of it as a function of my my
parameter why because as you change your
parameter the likelihood function will
change
since all my data points are independent
it's going to be the product over all my
data points
of the likelihood of any one data point
in the presence of this parameter so if
I told you Alpha was 5 and then you took
all these data points you could Loop
over each of these X I's and you could
plug them into here and you could get
that this is going to be equal to Alpha
divided by let me see if I get this
right
X
to the power of alpha plus one
but I don't just write X I write x i to
represent that first I take the first
data point then I take the second data
point and each time I plug them into the
probability Mass function
that's the likelihood but we don't
really need the likelihood what we
really need is the log likelihood so
remember the log likes to go and destroy
this whole thing and go inside
and then you get the log
of whatever your probability density
function was
one of your steps in mle and if you
solve this
it looks a little scary at first but
then you use your powers of logs and
you're like okay this is going to be log
of alpha
this is going to be minus Alpha plus 1
times log of x i
and at this point we've got our log
likelihood function
if we want to choose a value for Alpha
what we'd want to really find is what's
the derivative of this log likelihood
with respect to Alpha because what we
really want to figure out is which Alpha
makes this the largest we want to ARG
Max this
over all the arguments Alpha
so we have to derive this with respect
to Alpha so that's going to be equal to
the sum
from I equals 1 to n what's the
derivative of this term with respect to
Alpha
one over Alpha yeah fantastic
and what's the derivative of this term
with respect to Alpha e
well if you expand this would be
negative Alpha Times log of x i plus log
of x i and only one of these has an
alpha in it this would end up being
negative Alpha Times log of x i if you
drive that just becomes negative log
of x i
so that's the derivative and once you
have the derivative
you're laughing lots of optimization
techniques end with this if you can
write into a computer an expression for
the derivative you could just pass it
off to most commercial optimizers and it
would just give you back a value of
alpha that maximizes this
we have been using this trick of setting
this derivative equal to zero and if you
set this derivative equal to zero
I'm not going to write it on the board
but you know just be clear you got the
log likelihood
then we took the derivative of log
likelihood and we got this expression
oh and just to be clear
this expression
I often will put the sum as far inside
as I can and that would make this equal
to n divided by Alpha because this is
just one over Alpha added n times minus
the sum of log of x I's
now
as I said this is a pretty satisfying
answer most times I give exams this is
the final answer that I'm looking for
I'm like give me an expression for
derivative because if you can do
derivative you can do ARG Max but to
just drive that point home we can say
that the derivative equal to zero and
then we can solve for Alpha and if you
solve for Alpha you would get this
expression
and we've done this a whole bunch in
class we've done this to the point where
we can get an expression but we haven't
actually coded it up
if you set this derivative equal to zero
can somebody help me read this off the
board what's my expression for Alpha and
I'll put it with a little cute hat on it
okay what is it
F divided by
[Music]
all right
you know this is just an expression it
doesn't seem to mean that much
what I think really drives it home is we
could put this into code you can take
these observations and we can write our
estimate of Alpha and it takes these
observations
um
and you know we could try and write some
code here that instead of returning zero
estimates Alpha
so if I had to
code that expression up I would probably
do something like calculate my log sum
so I'd start equal to zero
for X I in my observations
I'd say log sum plus equals math.log of
x i
so this calculates that expression and
I'll Take N divided by that expression
what is n n is equal to the length of my
observations
and I would return n divided by log sum
and if I run this
it gives me back a number it says that
my estimate for this parameter Alpha
based on this data is equal to 2.7
oh come on
okay great so this expression you know
you could code it up and this would give
you equal to
2.7 would be my estimate for Alpha given
this particular data you know a lot of
times we use these xi's but I don't want
you to forget that in reality x I's will
be observations it's your data set from
which you're making your estimate
okay
that is the end of our wonderful journey
I know that was hard but like what a
Cornerstone of marcine learning that
you've learned today uh using the Disney
analogy that brings us to the end of our
wonderful movie
but of course there's always a sequel
come back on Wednesday and we will
continue this wonderful conversation you
guys are fantastic go to section
practice
miss you we will see you on Wednesday